bonjour lui pinto barreto
merci de venir jusqu'à mon ou devrais-je
plutôt dire dealer de livres si ça vous
voir vous avez lancé il y a un peu plus
de deux ans maintenant une librairie un
peu hors du commun cela s'appelle dealer
de livres et qu'on tient une librairie
classique cette librairie est basée dans
un conteneur sur le parvis de la gare
saint denis au nord de paris
rappelez-nous déjà le concept ben bon
jour un film et robert merci de
m'accueillir effectivement ma librairie
est basée dans un conteneur qui se
trouve sur le parvis de la gare de
saint-denis alors départ c'était juste
une table j'ai commencé à l'été 2010 9
et puis je voulais essayer pour c'était
nouveau pour moi donc j'ai commencé avec
une table et puis en septembre 2020 j'ai
fait installer un contenaire que j'ai
aménagé en librairie très vite l'idée a
pris nos sorts de trois ans plus tard
quel en est le bilan va gérer que c'est
beaucoup plutôt positif c'est beaucoup
de rencontres beaucoup de travail aussi
puisque c'est un métier que j'apprends
sur le tas suite à une reconversion
auparavant juste des techniciens de
maintenance de l'hôtellerie et hier
encore j'étais un événement où on
m'avait demandé de mettre en place une
sélection une table et l'âge aidant
dans le projet d'agrandir donc prendre à
contenir plus grand pour pouvoir avoir
plus de clients plus de livres j'ai
revenir sur vous tout à l'heure sur
votre parcours sur cette reconversion
même peut-être entre temps du lieu que
vous avez choisi pour installer dealer
de livres le parvis de la gare de
saint-denis la place des victimes du 17
octobre 61 exactement pourquoi cette
place alors l'idée c'était de mettre le
livre dans l'espace public
d'être le plus proche du public déjà
j'habite ce quartier donc c'était aussi
pour moi l'occasion de
d'avoir une action dans mon
environnement direct voilà qui est un
événement qui est assez décrié où il se
passe pas mal de choses il avait envie
d'apporter quelque chose de ba positif
de créer un espace d'échangés de
rencontres de débats de découverte donc
c'est toutes ces raisons là qui font que
je suis là aujourd'hui dealer de livre
vous dites dealer de livrer pas vendeur
de livres qu'elle est la nuance art
dealers de vivre c'est un petit jeu de
mot que j'ai trouvé à l'époque en 2015
quand j'ai créé ma ma chaîne youtube ce
qu'au départ c'était plus une un an que
je m'étais donné pour avoir une présence
sur les réseaux sociaux et puis pour
voilà comment ça un peu à faire des
chroniques entre guillemets littéraire
ans en parallèle de mon métier de mon
métier de technicien et c'est une langue
qui est resté puisque ça a accroché
après il y avait aussi un
l'idée de partir de quelque chose de
négatif pour le transformer en positif
donc c'est un projet commercial est ce
que vous arrivez à en vivre alors c'est
encore difficile on va dire c'est encore
les débuts maintenant on est quasiment
presque trois ans après mais j'ai bon
espoir et je m'organise au mieux pour
que le but c'est d'en vivre carreman
alors luc pinto baïeto comment ça se
passe vous êtes sur cette place là dans
votre conteneur est ce que les gens
s'arrêtent pour acheter des livres
qu'est ce qui change par rapport à une
libre et classique bad ces jeux qu'on se
dit déjà beaucoup le formant le format
et puis cet espace de la gare qui est un
peu un lieu de rencontre naturelle déjà
en temps normal beaucoup de gens si il
passe beaucoup de gens s'y donnent
rendez vous et il ya déjà là le format
du conteneur affectivement qui attire
qui est qui qui qui intéresse qui pose
question et puis moi je fais en sorte de
créer cet espace là pour que ce soit
aussi un lieu de rencontre pas
simplement être là et attendre que les
gens arrivent à moi mais qu'est-ce que
je peux faire pour créer de
l'interaction donc des rencontres dans
l'espace public est justement à l'image
on voit des gens réunis autour d'une
table devant votre votre conteneur
comment ça se passe de la bd des
conférences régulières des rencontres
sur quels thèmes comme alors c'est
l'idée c'est comme un peu un club de
lecture là c'était l'occasion d'une
rencontre sur un auteur haïtien jean
claude charles enfin sur son sur son
oeuvre et l'idée c'est de pouvoir
multiplier ce genre de rendez vous pas
nécessairement directement avec un livre
un auteur mais chapelle du théâtre de
deux des moments festifs aussi des
moments pas de papa spécialement des
moins que de débats et vraiment c'est ce
que j'aimerais pouvoir mettre en place
et ça se met en place petit à pied
puisque après du coup comme on est dans
l'espace public aussi on est liée aux
intempéries fin tout ce qui est tout ce
qui ce qui peut contraindre ces
événements il chante l'autre charles
auteur haïtien journalistes décédés
malheureusement mais dont l'oeuvre est
réédité chez mémoire d'encrier entre ma
mémoire est bonne votre slogan luc pinto
barreto ces lits plus apprend plus
échange le monde expliquez-nous du mois
s'expliquer à ce qui nous sauve vendredi
matin alors c'est un c'est pas mon
enfance et c'est une citation en fait
d'un rappeur que j'aime beaucoup qui
m'inspire beaucoup qui s'appelle nas etc
extrait d'un de ses morceaux qui
s'appelle ricaine qui est sorti dire il
ya plusieurs années et en fait ça fait
partie un peu d influence qui qui qui
qui qui me qui me concerne tout ce qui
concerne le hip hop le rap j'aime
beaucoup cet art cet art musical et
c'est une citation que j'avais retenu
qui me restait en tête et que j'ai
décidé de mettre sur mon compte nerfs
d'ailleurs pour qui m'inspire et kiki
qui m'invite à voile à agir dans le
monde environnement direct à travers les
livres notamment parce que si j'ai bien
compris vous avez dit aussi que votre
soi n'était pas de combattre
l'illettrisme ou quoi que ce soit ce
n'est pas un projet politique
ah non parce que effectivement quand je
me suis installé à la gare de saint
denis bossé a suscité plusieurs
réactions la majeur la grande la grande
majorité positives mais yahia dd il ya
des des stigmates disons qu'ils sont
attachés à cette ville à la 93e manière
générale qu'à la banlieue de mer général
que ce soit celle de paris ou autre ou
bon voilà il ya pu avoir des quelques
commentaires ou
certains ont jugé peut-être que je
venais pour sauver ou voilà pour
combattre l'illettrisme moi c'est pas du
tout mon intention une objectif était
beaucoup plus modeste saint denis on le
rappelle quand même pour ceux qui nous
suivent ces douze librairie pour une
population d'un million six cent mille
habitants de seine saint denis la seine
saint denis
quels sont vos critères de choix de
livres de titres alors moi ce que
j'essaye de mettre en avant c'est déjà
une sélection qui tourne autour des
mandats front on va dire donc que ce
soit de la littérature africaine
caribéenne tout ce qui concerne aussi
les problématiques disons deux sociétés
puisque ce que j'aime c'est ce qui m'a
donné envie d'être libre rs qui m'a
m'encourage à faire ça a saigné
notamment c'est le livre qu'on peut
appeler outil qui nous aide à réfléchir
un peu sur nous mêmes sur le monde dans
lequel on vit voilà aujourd'hui on voit
bien que les choses ne sont pas faciles
d'autant plus en seine saint denis après
voilà 2 ans de 3 ans de kovy douillet ça
a laissé beaucoup d'impact beaucoup de
traces donc c'est comme ça que j'essaie
de faire ma sélection puis en découvrant
aussi avec les personnes qui viennent me
voir en échangeant ma posture c'est pas
de d'être là et de dire c'est moi qui
sais c'est moi qui vais vous dire quoi
lire c'est plutôt créer cet espace et
échangeant donc vous avez une vraie
ligne éditoriale la littérature afro
mais pas uniquement celle littérature là
puisque vous êtes ouvert aussi bien
compris sur plein d'autres les gens on
ne va pas parler quel genre justement
les romans les essais du parieur a livré
l'on peut retrouver de tous les essais
la littérature littérature jeunesse les
bandes dessinées j'aime tous les formats
et j'ai des moines des enfants donc je
suis très intéressé pour la littérature
jeunesse est en photo on peut toujours
trouver des idées de lecture pour l'été
on arrive à la fin alors lien roman que
j'ai pris beaucoup apprécié la qui
s'appelle le duel des grands-mères de
diageo dembélé c'est un jeune auteur qui
est publié chez lattès et c'est un roman
magnifique où on revient sur le parcours
de l'auteur sont sa jeunesse au mali et
où on a tout un tas de dualité entre les
langues le monde des enfants le monde
des adultes des hommes des femmes est un
secret de famille qui va nous être
compter tout au long du roman entre ces
grands-mères pater sa grand mère
paternelle et sa grand mère maternelle
merci beaucoup merci à vallet d'être
venu jusqu'à non dealer de livres merci
pour vos conseils de lecture de cet été
c'est à l'invité paille direct liste
avec toutes les formations
internationales et françaises continuent
sur nos chaînes
[Musique]